alors question faut-il plus d'éoliennes
pour sortir du tout nucléaire est ce la
bonne stratégie pour avoir une
électricité propre et à prix convenable
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
arthur paris ce membre de l'association
des amis des leads et moore bonsoir
arthur parisse merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés en face en direct jean marc
governatori
coprésidents écologie au centre bonsoir
monsieur merci d'être avec nous vous
étiez candidat à la primaire des verts
je précise merci d'être en direct avec
mon amour un mot donc pour recommencer
sur ce témoignage qu'on vient d'entendre
cette femme bernadette car ça des mots
très durs ceux qui sont en faveur de
l'éolien sont ceux qui n'en subissent
pas les nuisances et qui sont intéressés
à la faire en tant qu élue écologiste
jean marc governatori
quelle est votre réaction à ce genre de
discours a évidemment en berne avec car
ce n'est pas forcément un témoignage
isolé il faut il faut bien vivre
à tout à fait tout à fait mais en france
et dans le monde on peut pas dire les
écologistes il y à différentes
sensibilités au sein des écologistes moi
je représente en france d'écologie
centriste et on n'est pas obsédé par les
éoliennes donc le fait est que l'ue ne
pas en vouloir plus quand même
en vouloir plus un accord avec des
habitants on peut pas travailler à nos
positions avec des habitants en france
aujourd'hui il y à 8000 éoliennes et les
huit éoliennes n'ont pas été imposée à
tous les habitants il ya des attentes
sont d'accord parce qu'ils sont
particulièrement écologistes ou
particulièrement sensibles à la
problématique énergétique mais moi me
suis pas un fana des éoliennes les deux
premières sources d'énergie sont d'abord
l'éducation à l'environnement parce
qu'on peut moins gaspiller et avoir
besoin d'au moins d'énergie et par
ailleurs l'isolation les deux premières
choses énergie qui sont bien celles là
isolation éducateurs environnement
l'éolien doit faire de remixer l'éthique
mais pour ce qui nous concerne nous
écologistes centristes nous est
favorable autre champ d'éoliennes et
nous sommes défavorables aux maires par
contre nous aimons ce qui est petit
parce que le vrai écologiste préféré des
petits as tes grands donc nous croyons
au mini éoliennes sur des toits
d'immeubles par exemple un immeuble fait
une bonne isolation et sur le toit vous
pouvez vous mettez du solaires et une
éolienne
vous allez vous approchez de l'autonomie
énergétique de l'immeuble en question
dans des écoles yeux une éolienne c'est
bien un 10-0 diane partout nous n'y
sommes pas favorables on en parlera
évidemment jean marc governatori parce
que on va aussi peut-être parler voilà
de l'efficacité c'est vrai que si vous
mettez pas beaucoup d'éoliennes
peut-être que ça va pas forcément
produire le résultat escompté mais enfin
on va on va revenir évidemment là dessus
alors cette question des éoliennes on
l'aura compris est elle provoque
vraiment une une fracture en désirant le
voir dans la classe politique je vous
propose d'écouter l'avis de celui qui
fait voilà beaucoup au débat en ce
moment votre candidat en tout cas vous
l'espérez puisqu'on rappelle toujours
qui ne s'est pas encore déclaré
officiellement eric zemmour voici ce qui
ce qu'ils en pensent tout le mal qu'il
pense de ces éoliennes
les éoliennes c'est une catastrophe on
n'en a pas besoin en france les
éoliennes c'est bon pour les pays qui
n'ont pas de nucléaire
rappelle qu'eric zemmour voilà même nom
officiellement candidat pour l'instant
est à 13 % dans les sondages donc c'est
une candidature qui devient évidemment
crédible et est intéressant donc on a
envie d'avoir votre avis ce soir c'est
un petit peu radicale on en n'a pas du
tout besoin en france des éoliennes
alors arthur pic en france on a peu
voire pas besoin pour une raison simple
c'est qu'on est extrêmement performant
sur nucléaire le nucléaire aujourd'hui
c'est une énergie qui est décarbonée
qu'il puissante et dont on a la maîtrise
depuis quarante à cinquante ans donc sur
la question de l'éolien effectivement
vous avez raison de souligner le sujet
il va falloir comparer la performance
énergétique et on réalise aujourd'hui on
savait déjà que sur la performance
énergétique de l'éolien face au
nucléaire on ne peut même pas les
comparer donc il s'agit aujourd'hui de
dire qu'il faut arrêter cette politique
de l'éolien qui est une pollution
visuelle déjà qui est une pollution
aussi
des terres ces 400 mètres cubes de béton
dans le sol c'est mille tonnes de béton
armé dans le sol ce sont des pales ont
fait importer de chine avec des produits
des minerais rares qu'on est incapable
de recycler qu'on enfouit dans les sols
qu'on exporte voir dans les pays
d'afrique pour les faire offrir là bas
donc cette réalité de l'éolien il faut
la voir dans son intégrité et
aujourd'hui le nucléaire est une réponse
parfaite adéquate aux enjeux
énergétiques qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui et dans les années à venir
vous voulez retirer alors si eric
zemmour
et l'ubs ont alors qu'il n'est pas
candidat rappelle un ton jour un tout de
même mais voilà il soit retiré tout
simplement n'ont alors pas
nécessairement aujourd'hui elles sont là
déjà ce qu'on peut faire c'est avant de
les retirer s'est arrêté d'en planter de
nouvelles aujourd'hui on a un exemple on
a plutôt un parfait contre exemple c'est
l'allemagne l'allemagne a appliqué la
politique écologique de monsieur depuis
dix ans c'est un nom dix ans plus tard
c'est 500 milliards d'euros investis
dans les énergies renouvelables un
abandon à 100% la filière nucléaire
c'est un échec total il ya un rapport de
la cour des comptes fédéral allemand qui
dit en fait on investit 500 milliards et
on a aucune évolution à la baisse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'allemagne c'est même pire l'allemagne
aujourd'hui pollue dix fois plus que la
france donc on voit que c'est un échec
total
idéologique qui mènent nulle part car
reste un sujet à caution et
effectivement on n'a pas encore une
cellule de fait news sur rt france mais
que l'allemagne pollue dix fois plus
vous pouvez vérifier j'ai vérifié je
suis certain voilà c'est bien un rapport
de la coupe de la cour des comptes
allemands donc vous pouvez vérifier tout
et tout est sûre en tout cas celle qui
fait la proposition de retirer toutes
les éoliennes du pays c'est la presse du
rassemblement national marine le pen
écouter
tout mon soutien aux pêcheurs qui
s'opposent courageusement aux éoliennes
en mer élue présidente de la république
je déconstruire est immédiatement en et
chantier éolien à terre et en mer et
supprimerait toute subvention à l'éolien
jean marc governatori ça vous fait
bondir quand même ce genre de
déclaration marine le pen qui raserait
toutes les éoliennes et les retirer
benoit st-amand
il est notoire que monsieur et madame le
pen sont pas des plus grands écologique
de la planète que ça suppose de
parfaitement connaître le sujet donc
quand on connaît bien le sujet on sait
que toute source d'énergie a des
avantages et des inconvénients
donc les énergies fossiles elle tue
l'énergie nucléaire elle est dangereuse
et effectivement l'éolien parmi les
énergies renouvelables la biomasse la
géothermie le solaire
il est la moins bonne je suis d'accord
l'éolien et celle la plus problématique
des énergies renouvelables cela dit
l'éolien a sa place dans le mix
énergétique
d'autre part il faut comprendre que
l'écologie est un projet société complet
si en allemagne vous continuez comme
c'est fait depuis 15 ans le
productivisme apte à pouvoir et de
consumérisme à pouvoir effectivement
vous avez de gros besoins énergétiques
étaient entonnés écologistes et comporte
un projet de société écologistes ça va
de pair avec d'autres décisions par
exemple faire moins de publicité par
exemple arrêter de compter des centres
commerciaux par exemple réhabiliter des
appartements vacants en france à 3
millions d'appartements vacants donc
c'est pas la peine d'en construire
d'autres y à il ya 10 millions de mètres
carrés de bureaux et d'utiliser qu'on
peut transformer l'appartement il ya
beaucoup de sujets qui peuvent faire que
la besoin de beaucoup moins d'énergie
parce que chaque fois que vous
construisez quelque chose vous avez
besoin d'énergie donc on peut bâtir une
société écologistes en prenant des
mesures dans leur ensemble pour avoir
besoin de moins d'énergie
aujourd'hui quand vous entendez ce
discours effectivement
vous répondez quoi aujourd'hui
en vous bah écoutez moi je n'arrive pas
à savoir si monsieur maîtrise son sujet
parce que déjà il rejoint mon avis sur
la vie d'eric zemmour notamment sur les
éoliennes je suis content d'entendre
aujourd'hui je crois bien s'en remettre
alors vous en voulez pas du tout mais en
fait moi je n'en doute pas par principe
je n'en veux pas que ça ne marche pas je
serais ravi de savoir que ça marche ça
ne marche pas donc moi s'ils voulaient
chasser pragmatique enfin on considère
que ça ne fonctionne pas on voit que ça
m'apporte absolument aucune production
énergétique comptable et surtout il faut
rappeler que c'est une énergie
intermittente une éolienne fonctionne 21
% de son activité sur la question du
nucléaire vous avez un fonctionnement à
100% ça fonctionne tous les jours de
l'année ensuite sur l'éolien vous êtes
dépendant du climat vous êtes dépendant
des métaux et donc des vents vous avez
un double double défaut et sur les
questions des besoins énergétiques je ne
suis toujours pas d'accord avec monsieur
on voit bien qu'on est en train
d'électrifier aujourd'hui tous les
moyens de transport c'est les voitures
c'est les vélos les trottinettes les
avions les bateaux donc sur ces deux
demandes en énergie et je ne parle même
pas des grandes entreprises qui existe
qui seront aussi elle toujours plus
gourmandes en énergie en énergie
électrique on a une demande qui est
colossal cette demande on a les moyens
d'y répondre avec eux une filière
extraordinaire qu'on maîtrise
parfaitement france on peut en être fier
et je crois que les français sont plutôt
fiers c'est la troisième filiale
industrielle française est donc
aujourd'hui cette technologie elle
répond à tous les besoins énergétiques
d'aujourd'hui de demain j'irai même plus
loin on est même on a été excédentaire
en production électrique et on a exporté
c'est vous dire à quel point aujourd'hui
c'est une technologie dont on a besoin
et surtout qu'on doit encourager
d'abord préciser que le réseau action
climat et l instance suprême en termes
d'environnement et de climat dans notre
pays puisqu'un rassemble la fondation
nicolas hulot hachiro l'environnement et
vf avec la sema liste régionale est la
plus performante en terme de projet pour
le team a donc je connais parfaitement
le sujet donc je répète que toutes les
tours d'énergie en des avantages et des
inconvénients le nucléaire au delà du
danger qu'ils représentent
ils mourront 100% dépendant de
l'extérieur c'est un vrai problème c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi les écologistes en
pièces que je représente soit sont
défavorables à la voiture électrique
c'est un fléau écologique un fléau
humain est un fléau financiers
géopolitique puisque là aussi c'est une
voiture électrique
grassement effectivement les bonus sur
les voitures électriques et pénalise les
autres
elle est aussi problématique que la
voiture technique donc on peut tout à
fait limité largement le besoin du
nucléaire les quelques mesures que tout
à l'heure mais qui soit bien clair que
toutes ses énergies à des avantages des
inconvénients mais si on reste sur une
société énergivore effectivement on va
continuer d'aller vers l'impasse et je
rappelle à monsieur que c'est selon les
zones que l'éolien est productif à 25%
du temps où 5 40% du temps où 70% du
temps selon le pilote mais c'est pareil
pour le nucléaire et rotin ce pour ne
pas être l'énergie terrain territoire
que à cause de la problématique plier à
une technologie très poussée il ya une
temps 30% des centrales nucléaires qui
ne mentionne pas en france donc la
france obtient aujourd'hui sur les deux
tiers des centrales nucléaires donc il
faut pas croire que tu es à la centrale
nucléaire marche c'est exact ce n'est
pas une énergie intermittente sauf que
le tir le tiers ou 30% des centrales
nucléaires ne fonctionne pas parce qu'il
ya des problèmes technologiques liés à
cette propre énergie arthur paraissait
voué à une autre alternative que
l'éolien pour réduire la part du
nucléaire dans notre consommation
énergétique
écouter aujourd'hui déjà pourquoi se
poser la question de la réduction de la
part du nucléaire si nucléaires
fonctionnent si le nucléaire est
performant et je le dis ça va agacer
monsieur surtout cynique les attendait
pas mais parlait effectivement
c'est clair et écologique parce que
c'est une énergie décarbonée aujourd'hui
la france il faut le rappeler le mix
énergétique français à 90 % à 90 % ont
produit d'énergie propre décarbonés à
100% donc c'est à dire un mix de
barrages hydro électriques et nucléaires
donc la france n'a pas à rougir elle
produit aujourd'hui son électricité de
manière 100% verte 90% et si on n'est
qu'à 90% ce parce que la politique
notamment que problème monsieur nous a
considérablement affaibli la filière du
nucléaire donc moi je vois pas pourquoi
faudrait se poser la question déjà
d'affaiblir ou de sortir d'une
technologie qui marche je rappelle
l'exemple de l'allemagne qui en est
sorti à 100 % à l'horizon 2020 2 et qui
dit c'est un échec total la cour des
comptes dit c'est un échec cuisant ces
500 milliards jetés à la poubelle donc
et je reviendrai sur un dernier point ça
nous rend de surcroît indépendant et non
pas dépendant de l'extérieur parce que
aujourd'hui la source qui permet de
produire le nucléaire on la trouve à peu
près partout dans les différents pays
dans le monde on la trouve aussi
notamment dans les océans
donc en plus il ya des enjeux de
souveraineté d'indépendance alors que
quand monsieur veut faire importer des
pales éoliennes et ne produisent rien
qui fonctionne 20% l'année qui ont
ensuite en viennent de chine ensuite
vous les renvoyer en afrique ou en
france ou ailleurs pour les enfouir je
ne comprends franchement je ne comprends
pas l'écologie qu'il ya derrière ça et
donc pour moi oui la proposition d'eric
zemmour si c'est une proposition
écologique mais encore faut-il être
capable de l'entendre sur les chiffres
et j'aimerais citer jean marc jancovici
qui est quand même une personne de
référence sur ces questions là qu'elle
crée un think tank de conseil
aujourd'hui il le dit de manière très
sérieuse il est pro nucléaire il est pro
nucléaire parce que les chiffres sont
avec le nucléaire
le mot de la fin pour vous jean marc
governatori huit mines et paulienne
aujourd'hui sur le territoire la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
et en prévoit elle qui a donné 20 milles
d'ici 2028 qu'est-ce qui vous évoque ce
chiffre c'est une folie puisque compte
aujourd'hui l'électricité en france est
peut-être la productivité d'une éolienne
la réponse aux besoins énergétiques de
notre pays c'est d'une part limité le
productivisme et limiter le grand
numérisme temps par exemple ou limiter
la publicité avait vous limiter les
besoins en énergie d'autre part
l'éducation à l'environnement d'autre
part isoler toute construction parce
qu'en plus ça crée des emplois qui sont
longs de l'école is able et quant au
nucléaire nous avons le devoir d
récupère sa part être de notre
dépendance parce que l'uranium nous
l'important est par ailleurs lu
nucléaire a besoin de beaucoup d'eau et
il n'a échappé à personne que nous pose
et on est père de chef de sécheresse et
donc c'est un vrai problème ce besoin
d'eau une qu'hier ils ne sont pas
nucléaire ne peut pas survivre sans eau
est donc sacré encore une problématique
ainsi effectivement il peut y avoir des
centrales nucléaires qui ne fonctionne
plus justement parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres parce que c'est là cherchent le
reste par conséquent il faut faire un
mix énergétique avec la géothermie la
biomasse le solaire de l'éolien est
évidemment l'éducation l'environnement
et l'isolation merci en tout cas tourné
dos jean marc governatori d'avoir été
avec nous en direct arthur paris sur ce
plateau merci à vous